Next question today is, David, how do you
think that these conspiracy theorists and
reactionary Republicans in Congress are going to
impact the next couple of years? Yeah, this is a
really good question. I actually have a sort of
backwards reverse approach to this, which is if
we I'm guessing that this viewer is referring to
people like Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Green,
Congresswoman Lauren Bobert, a
Congressman Madison Cawthorn,
who we saw earlier this week, just he doesn't
know anything. He can't answer simple questions.
I believe that whether they get reelected is
going to signal to us the legacy, the staying
power of Trump ism. And what I mean by that is
Bobert Green, Cawthorn and some of these others,
they rose to the House of Representatives
in November, riding on the wind, propelled
by the same sails that defended Trump ism, the
Trumpy and Cult. And they were running in the
right districts where these sort of kuhnen types
like Marjorie Taylor Green and the wild pro-gun
folks like Bobert and Cothran, they were able to
win because of the districts in which they ran
and sort of lifted by the vote of Trump ism.
With Trump gone now and a question we haven't
heard from Trump since he left office. We'll see
if we hear from him during the next two years.
Whether these people get reelected in November of
twenty. Twenty two will signal whether Trump ism
died with Trump and became relegated to basically
Internet conspiracy theories or whether it will
have the staying power to maintain a sort of
legislative power and a presence in the House
of Representatives. If you're not familiar with
some of these people, Marjorie Taylor Green, for
example, she represents Georgia's 14th District.
She has been a Kuhnen supporter. She talked about
some shooting being a false flag. I don't
remember if it was Parkland or Sandy Hook.
This is a really insane person who on January 21st
drafted articles of impeachment against Joe Biden.
Some of these folks are merely delusional.
Some of these folks are hungry for power
and they see playing these Trumpy and
characters as the way to get that power.
Some of them plan to use it to Grif their way
to something beyond being members of the House.
But this is going to be the big signal as to
whether the Republican Party really eats itself
or whether it says, OK, yeah, listen, these people
were an aberration. They won because of Trump,
but we're going to get them out in twenty, twenty
two. And I don't know the answer to that. I have
no advice for the Republican Party. What I do
think is clear is if you lost if in a two year
period between twenty eighteen and twenty twenty,
you lose the House of Representatives, you lose
the Senate and you lose the White House with a
president who makes himself a one term president,
you would think you would say it's time to learn
something from this. There's many things Democrats
should learn as well. I'm not saying Democrats
are exempt from learning from what happened,
but if Republicans learn from this, then they
will figure out how to get these people out and
to go back in the direction of, you know, people
like Mitt Romney. But but the truth is, given the
popularity of Ted Cruz, for example, and Louie
Gohmert and Matt Gates even before these whack
jobs were elected in November, it's not clear that
there's a big appetite for the Republican Party to
do that. So we'll see what happens. But I think
the legacy of the Republican Party will be in how
it deals with and this applies to both voters and
the party apparatus itself. How do they deal with
these wacky people that were elected in November?
Marjorie Taylor Green up there, Lauren Bobert,
Madison, Cawthorn. I think there are others. Those
are the three names that come to mind right away.